i'll be waiting late into the night
hopefully we'll know the result
that night because the last thing i
think we need is
a case going to the court over the
election with the deciding vote being
cast by a justice who was just appointed
by one of the litigants to the supreme
court
all right we're doing a quick on the fly
interview today with the legendary
lawyer legal scholar and one of the last
sane liberals around
alan dershowitz welcome to the reuben
report well thanks it's a pleasure to be
on with another sane liberal
there ain't many left to have our next
meeting in a phone booth
yeah there's about there's about 10 of
us left so i just said to you before we
started that i i'd love to have you back
for a full extended hour-long interview
that i normally do
i appreciate you jumping in today
because of the amy coney barrett
uh confirmation yesterday just to clean
up some of the some of the legal stuff i
know we could
complain about what's happened to the
libs all day long but but let's just
talk about some legal stuff today and
then we'll we'll pick up
and and do that in the next couple weeks
uh so first off she was confirmed
yesterday
i i suspect although you probably don't
agree with perhaps
all of her past judicial decisions or
some
of her reasoning that you think that her
being confirmed was the right decision
is that too much of a leading question
a little bit too much of a leading
question if a decision was going to be
made
it was the right decision that is she
was highly qualified
she is as qualified as merrick garland
but merrick garland should have been
confirmed
as well so i object to the process
i think the republicans stole a seat on
the supreme court
from the democrats and that was improper
back in
1990 2016. that was wrong
and they established a precedent which
they didn't follow
namely that if a nomination comes within
months
of an election it should be deferred but
passing that i basically agree with the
vote
that was made by the senator from alaska
she said she opposed the process but she
didn't want to take it out
on a highly qualified justice so yes
she's highly qualified no doubt about
that
right when we get into the hypocrisy
game of what the republicans did
just a couple years ago and and some of
the things that the democrats are saying
there's nobody that's innocent in that
right nobody's at this point it started
with um bork we have a verb now to bork
somebody
it then moved to abolishing the
cloture and filibuster first on
all judges then on supreme court
justices
and now of course this morning already
aoc and others
are demanding that the court be packed
there's a big op-ed or
in today's new york times a series of
op-eds about how to
fix the court i mean the only thing
broken about the court today essentially
is that it is dominated by conservatives
i don't think the people who wrote the
op-eds most of them
would have tried to fix the court if the
shoe were on the other foot
and if it were six to three in favor of
liberals they only want to fix it
because they want their ideology to
dominate on the court
so i'm curious back in 2013 when harry
reid
you know did the nuclear option i was a
lefty i was a big liberal i was a
democrat the whole thing and there is
video on youtube people can find it of
me
saying this is a bad move it will be
used against us that's exactly
what mitch mcconnell said back then what
were you saying same thing exactly
same thing look i've always taken the
view that i put the institution the
supreme court the country
before partisan politics that's what got
me in trouble with so many of my
so-called liberal friends who wouldn't
understand a liberal if they fell over
one
uh liberal friends who object to the
fact that i defended the constitution
when the house of representatives tried
to impeach president trump who i voted
against
in the 2016 election on unconstitutional
grounds
uh i favor the constitution and
institutional
support for the supreme court over any
kind of ideological preference
do you think that in normal times and i
i don't even know how to define that
anymore
that because we'd be talking more about
acb's uh qualifications rather than the
process
she strikes me as the type of person
that maybe maybe 30 years ago let's say
she probably would have got 70 votes or
something like that wow do you think
that's that's something like that's fair
to say i think 98 votes is fair to say
scalia got negative well oats and scalia
didn't try to hide his views
at all uh justice ginsburg got
many many many votes she didn't try to
hide her views the tradition back in the
day
was that you you affirm somebody for the
supreme court if they're highly
qualified that was broken for the first
time
with the bork nomination uh bork was
extremely qualified he was a professor
at yale he was listed a general
he was a judge but he had extreme
right-wing views and he didn't present
them
effectively um he made statements in
front of the senate which really put a
lot of people off including a lot of
republicans
and so he failed the confirmation
process test but it turned into more of
a principle
look when you get a court a supreme
court
that doesn't affect the lives of
ordinary people as the supreme court
didn't for the first hundred years of
its existence
nobody cared who was on the supreme
court but when the supreme court decides
desegregation as it should have roe
versus wade
uh gay marriage people are going to say
who are those
robed people what what why don't we get
input into who is put on the court
they're affecting our
daily lives so you know there's no free
lunch if you want the supreme court to
be depoliticized
then the supreme court should stay away
from making controversial divisive
decisions
if they're going to make controversial
decisions then they're going to become
politicized that's what democracy is all
about
i'm guessing that not much can shock you
but is any of the language coming
out of the democrats right now shocking
to you in that there's basically just a
let's burn it all down
feeling right now not just let's pack
the courts but let's change the
electoral college
let's change every institution that in
many ways someone like you has fought
for your whole life
to to strengthen yeah because they're
not interested in changing the
institutions they're interested in
getting their way
um and whatever it takes to get their
way they're prepared to
do um if the shoe were on the other foot
again they would be the strongest
offenders
of these various institutions but they
you know there's an intolerance
it reflects itself on campuses today why
do we need free speech we know the truth
why do we need due process we know if a
woman accuses a man of course
the woman is telling the truth and the
man is guilty
why do we need any of these processes we
know
we know the truth we're endowed with
this special
ability to discern truth and we don't
need process we don't need
speech we don't need due process we
don't need
the supreme court we don't need the
electoral college we don't need
anything just give us the ability to
rule and dictate
and will dictate in the right way said
stalin and mao
and many of the students on college
campuses today
so i'm curious with that in mind i've
been making an argument and i did not
vote for trump four years ago i voted
for gary johnson but i am going to vote
for trump this time
i've been making an argument that in an
odd way trump is defending
both liberalism and conservatism at this
point in that he's defending
conservatism that's obvious the judges
and and the policies are fairly
conservative and he's defending
liberalism because he's basically the
last
the last door between the the lefties
just ramming through
everything does does that make some kind
of sense to you well
as bizarre as it sounds liberalism
unintentionally he's defending
liberalism and many conservatives defend
liberalism today because it's their ox
that's getting bored
by the extreme left but remember i'm old
enough you're not to remember when it
was the conservatives
who were suppressing free speech on
campus i grew up during mccarthyism
and so as you said in the beginning
there's enough hypocrisy to go around
on both sides what we need is a core
of liberal centrists conservative
centrists
who have to work together to preserve
institutions
without regard to what the outcome is we
have to be focused on
process and fairness it was felix
frankfurter the great justice
who said the history of liberty is
primarily the history of process and
procedure
if you get that right you're going to
lose the outcome sometimes
but next time you'll win but if you
change the process
and eliminate due process and free
speech democracy is done
do you think there's enough of those
liberals of of those centrists are are
there any left i mean we can joke about
you know there being about 10 of us
obviously there are other you know just
good
folks out there but it seems like
they've lost all power i don't see any
of them
represented by the democrats at the
moment i mean where are they well i
think you're right
i would have thought that joe biden
would be one of the last
of the liberals the centrist liberals
and i hope maybe he will be
but he has to resist the pressure
from the squad and from the people on
the extreme left look we're going to see
a move toward court packing immediately
and i know that joe biden doesn't want
to pack the court and i know he won't
push
court packing but what if the senate and
the house passes court packing
will he veto it does he have the courage
to stand up
against his own party radicals and veto
it i think that's the great question
and i agree with you we need to build
the center we need to build
look i used to have these great debates
with bill buckley
he was a centrist conservative i'm a
center as liberal you and i can have
these debates but i can't have any
discussions with anybody on martha's
vineyard
i can't have discussions with members of
my own family
they just know the truth they want the
outcome they want
and anything that stands in the way of
that is fascism
so i'm now ashes because i believe in
due process
hey you're in good company um all right
so i will obviously spend a lot more
time talking about that in a separate
interview but
but i just let's dive into it a little
bit more here because i think a lot of
people watching this especially just
you know basically a week before the
election at this point they're feeling
that
these are people who are lifetime
lifetime moderate conservatives or
moderate liberals who now
family members won't talk to them
they're being pushed out of their
communities and
when do you remember as someone that
comes from the institutions that comes
from harvard that has been in the media
game
for decades do you remember was there a
moment that you saw
that you got whoa this thing really is
out of control yeah i think
i think it really did come to fruition
with the election of donald trump who
did
reflect a division in the country look
there's still some place
that people can go to they can listen to
you and they can listen to i have a
podcast now too called the durst show
it's
the dirt show
i always represent kind of the center
liberal position never take positions on
who should be elected or who should be
appointed i
talk about the implications of what's
going on in america and you can get it
you know on spotify or youtube so you
know listen to you
listen to me we'll link to it and i do
think that podcasts and
things like that are the wave of the
future because
look tate look what's going on today
with hunter biden i
i'm a liberal democrat i like joe biden
i don't believe he's corrupt
but npr and national public radio
has now made a policy that they won't
report on whether or not the laptop
is genuine or not i want to know whether
the laptop is
genuine i want that to influence my vote
one way
or another maybe it's not enough to
change my
current predisposition but i'm entitled
to know and twitter and facebook and npr
are not entitled to keep that
information from me
are are you shocked then at the way that
the media
has crumbled in in conjunction
with all of this because you know i'll
see a lot of times when when you go on
cnn or
or now you go on fox or whatever it
might be and by the way fox is the only
one that puts me on the cnn span me as
well
yeah oh they ban you congratulations but
but i see you
when when you've gone on there i
suddenly see people who you've taught
people that were your former colleagues
people that that you might have even
learned from
who are suddenly going off on you in the
in the worst
sort of ways and and usually have almost
no legal backing behind what they're
doing and then you get lay out a calm
legal president
but they're basically just calling you
names well that's and i'm constantly
amazed by that true of geoffrey tube and
and
and yeah you know jeffrey tooken was my
student and the point is jeffrey toobin
has been wrong 100
of the time when he's predicted the
outcome of court decisions and i've been
right 100 percent of the time it's not
that i'm smarter than tuban
it's that he allows ideology to
influence his predictions cnn tells him
essentially how to come out because he
doesn't want listeners of cnn to be
upset that the supreme court may come
out in a way different from his
prediction and i don't care about that
and so i get it right because i don't
allow ideology to skew
my predictions i follow what oliver
wendell holmes said the job of a lawyer
is to predict in fact what the courts
will do not what the courts
should do so toobin has gotten it wrong
and i've asked cnn probably why i've
been banned
i've been asking cnn show two bin's
predictions
and then show what happened so that the
listeners and the viewers
can judge him and decide whether to
listen to what he has to say
then show my predictions and show what
happened they of course won't do that
because people don't care really about
the truth
they only care about their truth their
capital t truth
so i know i know that you might be in
the legal prediction game but nobody
wants to be in the political prediction
game
you know seven days out but what do you
think i mean what do you think's gonna
happen at this point
i can't predict i'm not in a position to
make that judgment i did predict in 2016
in
august that trump may well win and i
told that to hillary clinton who i was
supporting because i had just come back
from europe and i had seen the growth of
populism
brexit all that and i saw a wave
sweeping the world and i thought it
would sweep america as well
and i got that right but i don't know
how to assess the polls the poll show
biden ahead
obviously but we know that there's a gap
between polls and trump voters because
there are a lot of trump voters who
won't tell pollsters the truth
so i'll be waiting late into the night
hopefully we'll know the result
that night because the last thing i
think we need is
a case going to the court over the
election with the deciding vote being
cast by a justice who was just appointed
by one of the litigants to the supreme
court so i hope we avoid that
right but doesn't it seem in a bizarre
way that that is sort of almost where we
have to end up now that the world has
gotten so crazy and that
you know i keep telling people it feels
like we're in the odd stage of democracy
where it's now just the show must go on
we just need the show in an odd way to
keep us all
focused on that that it would ultimately
lead us
to taking this to the supreme court
because in a bizarre sense that's the
show
well if it goes to the supreme court i
hope that whoever loses will do
what al gore did and what richard nixon
did and
concede defeat and have peaceful
transition
let's hope that happens i think there's
some possibility the election
may be decided on that night if florida
pennsylvania ohio michigan
all go for one candidate that will
probably be the winning candidate
all right let me ask you one other thing
for now and then we will we will pick
this up in the next couple weeks
for the so i get that on the left
there's this burn it down
feeling and they want to change all of
the norms but what i'm also seeing now
as i've been let's say more welcomed on
the right is there's a version of that
on the right as well which is oh well
the lefties are so bananas and the
institutions have failed us at such a
level that we also
should burn it all down i'm not a full
burn it all down
guy right i want to keep some of those
things for the reasons you just laid out
there
what would you say to the conservatives
who
who now hold that position or especially
if trump loses who at that point they're
all going to say all right
they wanted to burn it well now we'll
show them who's boss well
i've already commented on that with
lindsey graham who i liked as a
person lindsey graham said look uh i'm
never going to allow a nomination at the
supreme court to come within a year of
an election and you can
use my words against me so they used his
words against them and he said no no no
the rules changed
after what they did to the
prior uh justice uh to kavanaugh and
they raised all these fake issues about
you know his 15 year old and he said i'm
going to burn it down basically he
didn't use the words burn it down
but i'm going to change the rules i
don't think that's right
i don't think you fight dirty politics
with dirty politics
uh and i hope that if whoever wins
continues to play by the rules none of
us will gain by a burning
down mentality because you know who
they're gonna burn down
they're gonna burn us down we're gonna
be the guys who they
burn down and if you think you're exempt
from that forget about it
just remember the french revolution
nobody could get
far enough left to avoid being
guillotined even the people who thought
they were leading the french revolution
ended up losing their
heads when you have violence and riots
and the kinds of lawlessness that i
think
both sides are capable of engaging in
the losers are our democracy so you know
get ready to lose whether you're a
democrat
or a republican and then prepare to win
next time that's the answer
don't go to the streets and don't engage
in violence and
i'm afraid we may have some violence uh
following this election
and that's a great concern yeah spoken
like
a true liberal and as a guy that's a
talking head for a living i'd like to
keep my head attached to my body
so we shall see we shall see all right
the dirt show is available on itunes and
youtube and spotify and everywhere
that you can get podcasts and we'll get
you back after the election and we'll
we'll unpack those that would be
wonderful i had a great time talking to
you you're a terrific host
thanks alan i appreciate it if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversation about law instead of the
non-stop yelling you get everywhere else
check out our law playlist and if you
want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell